well since last time I saw you a lot of
kid been coming up I said damn I just
thought I I said I I just thought of
this so what's been going on this what
do you talk about today well I'll talk
about some of the issues I had a couple
of couple of inches they had one one
issue that traumatized me as far as when
I saw my brother hit by a car another is
my sexual addiction to Dennis Davis
behind some [ __ ] that some people did to
me when I little what happened your
brother well I was about 5 years old
he's about four years old and the ice
cream truck would come down the street
all the time he would come and he did
the other side is the other side seat of
the house so my mother the particular
morning ran over to the ice cream
dropping he ran behind her now the truck
is pointed this way and I'm over here on
this side of the street now i-i've seen
TV but I never seen I never seen blood
before I never seen nobody actually had
got hit by a car that really [ __ ] up
and especially I did when I was young
like that I really didn't know what
would look what what what the the
feeling of love or anything or that I
that I really loved my brother you when
I'm talking about least one of crackers
I mean anyway so my mother tells them
she says go back across the street
there's a guy you know black for sorrow
we got to lower he had a lowrider he's
got his musical doubt he's coming down
the street and I was said by the time of
mother says run back run back he runs
back up behind in front of the truck and
I remember it is then the noise and
seeing my brother and everybody going
like this and I remember when he hit
when he when he when he when he when he
landed in the street he like he like
bounced a couple of times and I remember
my mother ran out to get him he had him
on his on the sidewalk and I remember my
mom going into his shop he had my little
brother in arms just don't die don't die
and I'm just just I remember me me and
my mother we were I flew but you I was
just shaking so in this event the
ambulance came and and they come dad
give her some kind of sedative calm her
down and we time I'll give it me
something because I was I was I was just
I was just I don't know what to do but
again I didn't understand my emotions so
I was
I was I was five as he was four and I
remember they had to this little girl
next door any wasn't babysitting Sonya
he had to go to her house while they
went to the the hospital
and so Sonya had this rocking chair his
old rocking chair and when Iraqi had had
a chime on the bottom of it
you don't like to chime from it when you
have the boxes do we open the boxing
ding ding nothing little ballerina goes
around and that particular chair had
this had this dis music from that chair
and I remember that song went on she's
rocking in as song won and I was
visualizing my brother flying in the air
I mean I'm I mean as old as I am I still
you know when I talk about it it still
hurts me and I remember I told her stop
rocking in that chair just stop and so
absolutely I guess the body here later I
didn't know how that really affected me
they had a they had a new series of
robot that opened up over by though by
them all so we went into this in Roebuck
so my mom my sister looking at these
things on when they have the perfumes
and medications they have there so they
open up this box and there's since
little ballerina girl she comes up Bing
bong and she'll ding-ding-ding that she
and I and I heard that and I hear that
song and I remember mother as I'm with
you and it's like it's like all that
came back and I said I said I said close
the box mom I go so fast she says no so
they open so my sister's they started to
open anyway I took the buck the first
one they open I took I picked it up off
the show and then when I broke the glass
room on a serious show and I ran and
they had there was like the women's
section they had like these long gowns
and I ran up under the under the the
breck and I hate it now I was just I'm
just
just shaking I remember they went got to
secreting a security guard had they had
they had to have two security guards
it's kind of fun yeah I thought I was I
remember I was holding on to the pole
and he had our to screen they were
pulling me oh no no I don't want cuz I I
kept visualizing my brother get hit by a
car man I kept kid just like when I talk
about today my poor brothers blood goes
down his head and was all over and I
remember and I remember what my but my
dad my father's dead [ __ ] anyhow so when
he came home
beat my mother he came obese what
happened to my [ __ ] son where's my
[ __ ] so did you brother died no no he
didn't die he did die you can't even
keep it took him a few months but even
covered he's doing real good now you can
see you still see the bruise on his face
anyway my father comes home that night
and um I'm fires no man a [ __ ] I never
I never quit sleeping I mean in bed in
it he says what happened my [ __ ] son
whatever my [ __ ] son I grabbed my
[ __ ] son she said he got hit by the
car no he didn't you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
did you push him push him and bam hits
in the face I remember he threw it he
threw over the over the we have all we
had we had a back in the day they caught
it they call it a Wi-Fi stereo and
remember he tossed over the Wi-Fi stone
she comes in a white box to him she
tries me in the back and he grabbed me
puts her down on the ground and he puts
us if he puts his foot on her like put
his foot like on her neck and he had her
and I remember I'm standing there and my
head told me go get a knife out of the
kitchen go get a knife out of the
kitchen
so I run to the kitchen again at once it
got on my mama cutter on my momma three
back hands me I am be back guys me I
made on a four more time everybody was
kind of playing but one that when I when
I get to when I get in he's and I I just
shake and I just in the file I went
behind this - he goes when he anyway
went behind his throw and I - see like
this just with you again they had a poem
over the [ __ ] stereo and I got so my
dad said well it's about time to get him
into some therapy so I didn't get into
theater later on later on the life but I
wanna don't wanna don't want to go talk
about something else have my life as a
as a child how was them I was molested a
couple of times and I'm the first time
was molested the the I had a babysitter
and my babysitter was I guess she's
bought 13 13 years old I mean I still
remember an add-on for neon tissue
you know she came over and she would
always kind of look at me funny so the
girl was tending bar named Sonya the
girl - rocking chair she was over one
day and she said we were sitting on the
couch and she said do you guys like each
other I'm like I'm a boy I'm like no
girls on our girls so many bears to tell
she had me she had me take my index
finger and rub it on her vagina and in
taste it I did that and I remember when
I did I'm I remember I remember this the
smell of it was so it was like it was
like her but anyway that time as that
time went on it mean it made me curious
about because I liked the way it looked
I mean like the way it looked I like to
it look so when about a week ago a week
later she was sitting on the she waits
you baby sensing there's only she and I
there and she was sitting on the toilet
and I don't I don't know for what in the
world reasons made me come up to her I
said I walked in the bathroom when I
hear my mom Bob I'm about six years old
and I said well let me see it and she's
she sitting like this I said I said well
let me see it and she says see what I
said you know and I remember now I
remember this like it was yesterday
I remember she did like this and she
kind of opened her lips and she said lay
on the floor I had no idea what she said
lay on the floor I laid on the floor I
remember I remember I laid on my back I
was six years old she's 13 I laid on the
floor you know I don't I don't I don't I
don't remember what it feel like but I
know whatever she did she she got up on
top of me and she did something like
this and she started she started she
kept out after well how does it feel
well how does it feel I felt like at
first I thought she first thought she
was going to atrani I don't know I
thought she was some kind of killer so
it goes scared scared scared scared of
me with you I mean it scared the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of me
you know I kind of started to like it I
kind of cuz I mean yeah nice [ __ ] tits
and I'm a little boy you know we curious
about you know blue boys curious about
you know teach this stuff so I kind of
liked it
so I didn't know that that would doubt
would carry on to me up to this day
because I'm I remember I thought I've
never my life told about I remember I
remember I thought that every lady that
babysitting me was supposed to at least
at least
initiate sex I and I I don't care if it
was my grandmother my antique my sister
my auntie if I thought you had a nice
ass and even a secret oh and I will use
with babies you know we were supposed to
do something I remember
I had a Oh God I never do oh I had a I
had I had a cousin of mine
I guess she's about 20 years old and I
used to get bronchitis that it had to go
go home sick and I remember I was I was
there in there and the liberal fellow
sitting out watch it mighty mama mind
him off on TV and um she was laying her
she had [ __ ] Jesse's they had these
calling hot pants helo hot shorts on he
laying on the couch kind of like this
and I remember when she woke up I was I
was I was standing over and she's kind
of she kind of woke up what are you
doing what are you doing and I I said
can I see it she said what are you
talking about I said can I see it
what the hell you can go and wash your
mouth out with soap she told me next
thing I know about an hour later she
said let me show you how to do something
okay what are we gonna do I'm thinking
she's gonna get on top me and we don't
know she said he's there from there she
said taste it what the hell I'll take
the kids visit so I remember I remember
I remember I remember one out before I
did I remember it would just dismay oh
oh I mean it would be just now yeah that
kind of like to smell not when you're
back minutes right I could to smell just
somebody I want to smell baby just put
it everywhere she told me it was I guess
who's her clitoris it was it was kind of
sticking up and she said enough I see
you used to call a penis Siddiqui that's
it thank you got it dinky like me I
don't know women I don't know she said
we'll put you to put your tongue on the
bottom of it I'm six years old put your
tongue on the bottom of anyone I want
telling the bottom of it she told me she
told me how I were to rub my tongue and
I remember I could remember this do like
it was here I remember almost almost
said her name I remember I remember her
legs hurt and she said she's a go faster
go go faster I remember legs are going
like this I wonder what they no no no no
no I remember now I know what TV was an
orgasm she had but I remember when when
she did that I thought she I thought she
had she had
urine in my face because all this stuff
was in my face and I had just had a bad
smell to a number run to the bat walk
someone tell my daddy what he said wash
mercy huh
everything she said if you ever if you
ever [ __ ] tell anyway what we did I'm
gonna I'm gonna I don't put it so anyway
we did that and now I wanted to I wanted
eyes you know proper but the other girl
had that in the bathroom I said what can
I do that too
and that day she didn't let me do it I
think I might have been about a month
later and she initiated me when I was
sleeping because I when I was sleep
I guess cuz I was always I was always
kicking mine I was always one wondering
at home and and me and my sisters and my
sisters brothers we used to play like we
were at least hump on each other like
you know we were you know like we were
having the sex didn't know what the hell
we doing what we we did it yeah we dry
[ __ ] talk we talk John Rocker on all the
time we did we did all the time I was
the one who initiated all the time
because what that what had was that I
was always the one initiated and plus I
used was a little kid I just like to
watch it well one day we event aging
were the two twins estate next door and
we had a cardboard box in the backyard
and we had like a gate where you
couldn't see so me my little brother we
had he been aging in the backyard I said
almost adjustable I say man you don't
want to see something and we should call
it Lisa Cochran Lisa calls it the home I
said you only want me to teach you how
to do two home
well her brother says okay what is that
so oh god I came to I'm telling you this
so we have that we have the car border
in the backyard you know invest laying
down agent was the big one always like
fact I hear me say he was a fat one I
remember we told him lay down on the on
the on the thing and they didn't want to
do it
so I don't know where I guess because my
dad was always out I wanted to be I was
thought I was supposed to be the
dominating one I saw you oh you gonna do
it oh you [ __ ] go oh you you [ __ ]
gonna do this
no no I'm gonna try to run so I'm I
grabbed her you know back in the day
women are whether those little dress and
I'm not pulling for a dress and I don't
know what the hell out but I know I just
know I got on top of my little brother
so all of a sudden you can hear you hear
audio John oh my daughter's what are you
doing to my daughters boom all that says
oh my god so she called the police on me
my brothers and she told us she told my
mom my mother never told my my father
they killed
my mother my father but the word had had
it on the whole block that me and my
brothers
the women were off-limits to us from
from way back I was I guess I was but I
might have been about seven in the
world's are off-limits us they said we
were the we were the pervert to the
neighborhood so I remember I remember I
had it's just like I've never had like
this half-sister Rock sacani I didn't
really have a crush on her but I kind of
had a crush on her
I just liked the way she was she was
tick I was like to wish she was shape so
we're not turning right now my cell you
know what how come you never let me see
you go to the bathroom she said what are
you because I had a problem at that
because I just like to watch girls go to
the bathroom I even one time one time I
had I put a hole I put a hole in the
wall I put a hole in a wall so I could
watch my went in my mouth so she was
being her pee and I'd be looking through
a hole in the wall you know and we kind
of wagon off I used to do that and that
begins some some real pervert lesions in
my life so anyway always what I remember
when they have a show come on TV call
call love American style we weren't we
weren't we weren't supposed to watch
that we do so I would stay out late at
night and my grandfather and they would
be watching it and I will look through
the door and for some reason I always
always I thought I thought that every
time you used useful I just thought sex
you you had to touch I thought you want
you had to screw something I was I
always wanted to screw
I remember watching love American style
and I wanted to see like I just knew it
I know they're gonna [ __ ] I know that
kind of fathers cover that's a no
they're gonna [ __ ] every dish one day
I found a porno magazine
think it's my dad a Playboy magazine
here we go
I was about maybe six years old we moved
from where we were to another place and
they had white kids the world was going
so there I'd seen this blonde and just
bonding and in the centerfold and I
remember seeing us oh man I was like wow
but I never I've seen you know white
people on TV but I've never really seen
one so what does it went to this other
school come on keV it I'm gonna chase
went to this other school I've always
been bold I was just asked so anyway
when I remember my last name starts with
a B so her last thing started to be so
when they lined you up to go
to go to class you have to line up in
alphabetical order every day
so I remember when I'm standing in line
and they start call remember I looked
over and there was a girl named Ruth
whatever I remember I remember seeing
her shiny blue eyes and a long thick
bond here's your long they just yeah
just a little dress on is the other nice
little round you know behind I remember
I looked at her and I remember the
teacher actually what DT was wonderful
something wrong with me
the teacher told my momma something was
wrong me because I couldn't stop staring
I thought that was I thought that was
the most beautiful [ __ ] thing I've
ever seen in my life I've seen this
white girl standing there another thing
I got all wrong wait anyway so one day
we were we had we were playing this just
um where you put the whole binder and
everybody watch the truth - and I said
what can I know so one day we were
standing line since she was in the front
I was in the front room that's a rule
can I see it she said what are you
talking about I cannot see it she said
well I said I got I said I can you
snicker bar from let me see it she said
what do you want to see I said you know
I'm infinite doing it like that so I
guess is about about a week later I
asked her again I said I said me Ruth
can I see it was okay was it were the
classroom we had our classrooms like
rumor 19 was on the top now on the
bottom the restroom was like right here
so we had we had to go to the stairs so
we had to go up the stairs and back to
them so anyway for some reason we were
we had we were coming from the I don't
where we were both coming we were kind
of crossing and I said she said hey she
said she called me a boy I guess you
know hey boy you still got that candy
bar she said she said you want to go in
the bathroom I said yeah we're going to
bathroom so I went in the bathroom we
went in the bathroom I said she said
give me the candy bar Oh God and she
just kind of trying to flash around they
were like I said no I really want to see
it so I remember she pulled her when she
opened up her pants I put my finger in I
want it I want it I figured I figured it
over like woman had a different I want
to know what it tastes like no I'm here
I am what six seven years old so I
remember from my finger in there never
taste too bad that little until some
kind of way her big brother got word of
what we had done
he didn't mess with me because my
brother he wouldn't told his mother so
his mother told the principal who told
my teacher because they didn't and I
lied I lied a lot and my mother told me
I know what you [ __ ] did I know what
you [ __ ] and she said what did you do
some art artist she said no no what did
you [ __ ] do I said I just I just just
don't show me what you did I said no she
should show me what you did
I sure what I did so I went on thinking
that was what life was about everybody
wanted me to either put my tongue or my
finger between their [ __ ] legs
now as I grew up I always had a
fucked-up self-esteem I've never I mean
I think I was himself I never always had
a fucked-up self-esteem I was always a
loner always to myself but even to this
day the traumatization of that [ __ ]
bill when I hit [ __ ] barrowing that
did the chimer that thing it just God it
just drives me crazy just [ __ ] drives
me crazy he will go back with a beggar
so when I got to when I got to night
night I never I never had never never
had sex before never had sex before that
I was about 16 years old and I remember
well it sounds if you had did when you
were six years old no but that I don't
know if that count
I guess that's what I did but I never
you know I'm never anyway yeah I did
that - it was good yeah understood me I
know you did a whole lot I don't matter
I did even Adrian I did the other girl
down the street I did a few my cousin's
I don't throw my sisters me and my
sisters yeah so she's a hump my cousin
paid me my cut mother cousin they we
just did you hump they wanted a pay pay
the $3 to do the hump we did to hump
meet it to $3.00 home if I if I had if I
jump up a little bit mice know where I'm
going my self-esteem was always [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] on out myself she was always
[ __ ] up so I met this girl when I was
about I'm gonna skip him to go back I
miss his girl when I was I was about 16
years old one of those beautiful women
in school I walked her home I carried I
saw I just like to watch The Brady Bunch
I anyway
I carried the books home for her from
school
so she had me come over a house one day
and she was doing shorthand and I don't
know some cyclist she said tell me what
I'm writing I said you riding it you
want I said you write it you want me to
you want me do you want me to taste that
[ __ ] I said it just like that
she said how did you know let's run
upstairs now here I am I'm six don't
ain't never I'm scared to [ __ ] death
she takes me up to say we brushed she's
taking upstairs and I remember she had
these these really she's really peaked
like lots of opinions on and she's I'm
honest I don't want you to see it just
kind of stick just kind of stick what
you got you know kind of dig it in there
so I said I'm thinking I'm thinking um
I'll do I don't have chillie said I
taste each other for my finger in the
first said I didn't want to know I had
so I said well I said what the hell so I
remember I could pull her pants and sign
up for my face in it I remember I
remember thinking back when I went sin
sin but I did was say it said she got
that word legs were shaking and I and
she kind of did that too so anyway I'm
thinking any one of you just tell along
always been kind of big okay so when I
you had the sex with her she said god
that's the biggest dick ever saw in my
life he says God you did so so [ __ ]
good so and so
I'm literally every single day for about
two years she was supposed to go to the
prom and she took her money for the prom
I bought me a brand-new pair of blue
Nike so I said I don't handle
conversation I don't have no money
that's how you get paid so I've been
getting women in front of all of my life
[ __ ] inputs him and Jamie and [ __ ]
him and I'm getting getting paid pretty
much I I would I wouldn't call myself up
I'm not seeing that to brag I'm seeing
him into the Berenstain because I've
never had a I've never thought of myself
esteem is just all [ __ ] up I'm gonna
jump up and jump up because now now now
I'm 57 years old an old Petersburg or
Petersburg don't jump like he used to
so I'm having a hard time getting a
woman because I don't have nothing I
don't I don't have I don't have nothing
and they run for me then most time I
can't get up a nanny running for me and
I was kind of [ __ ] but anyway I said
it's a safe from from the time I was six
years old and going in and now all the
things that but all the drama tears
but what's going on with me was
basically because I got molested as a
child and I and it and it really I never
had nobody to do and when the person
that did to me my family what I don't
give a [ __ ] evil
there's years ago I just I think about
that [ __ ] and I and I just and sometimes
I get a resentment and I treat that
person real bad I mean I treat that
person real bad I never you know and
I've often got mad at her and wanted to
say you [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what you
[ __ ] did to me that's why I'm using
[ __ ] gross I can't stand the pain but
what from once I when I was I was
younger what the [ __ ] you did to me and
I can't talk nobody father [ __ ]
father would kill that [ __ ] you know so
wow I can't leave I told that so anyway
as I was growing up I remember I was I
was I was singing in my grandmother's
Monte's anybody that stated I remember
sitting I remember sitting my
grandmother on oh I really like me a
whole lot she I was her favorite because
I was I was her faith because I was
least I was a black sheep of the family
nobody ever never really liked me
I wear the glasses I was ugly I didn't I
didn't bathe that much I was just lazy
and sorry just slothful you know and not
honor and I think I did that to get
attention because I couldn't get the
attention of other way but I remember I
my father I just think my dad hated me
you know because my daddy just he just
it was never meant Pazos all your sorry
you're dumb look at you you can't this
and he's I used to want I just was it
and why why don't you love me do why
don't you why don't you know why would
you bother why you why didn't you step
on me every to everything I did
everything I said and all i'ma jump on
jump on your back even even when I had
my child I had my child and he's like
him on one day there's a server [ __ ] he
said look at Louis playing dad ain't no
[ __ ] daddy could you imagine how that
[ __ ] cut me I'm sitting there so you
worthless son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
think I think that's the first time I
got my my dad when he wouldn't let he
was
even let me talk back you my father was
a military you couldn't you couldn't you
could I think one other I hate to go up
so much I'm gonna tell my father he was
a man he was kind of guy he I'm never
sergeant told me one time he said never
take all of our man's pride my father
took all my pride never buck up I think
the first time I ever bucked up on mine
when he said when he said was playing
daddy with my kid my father has my
father had about 30 kids I mean little
his kids my father's I did women just
can't say couldn't say no to my dad he
just air the kids over the place I said
I tell you what partner I know something
I said I got one kid I know where my kid
is and if I got spend any money why can
i got spend money on one kid I ain't got
[ __ ] kids all over the [ __ ]
goddamn City over goddamn long so we're
at our and guys put on my [ __ ]
my my money go right here I know
something about being [ __ ] daddy
somebody else don't I remember to hold
my daddy's big dinners in my desk house
no no no no he didn't say that did you
say oh so no more monsters their mother
said leave Malone don't let him get it
out okay he's okay [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] we never we never really
discussed it but it was it was it was a
good thing that I got to have my tail
off my chest I want to see you stop you
stop ostracize me son of a [ __ ] you you
stop down to me and telling me to this
day dude I love to lift young young
young me enough I never I never ever
will talk now I'm gonna [ __ ] I've
never ever talked down on a cave when
they talk down on me
I remember hear this lady one time she
told her daughter get your sorry ugly
ass in the McDonald's I said whoa whoa
whoa whoa
she's not sorry you know those guys if
you tell her [ __ ] like that she's gonna
Rob [ __ ] up like me I mean that lady
she look like one of the big tough
ladies she turns to you might be right I
mean that's how they talk to me I'm
system I think it's sometimes I think
maybe my dad talked to me that way
because he felt like I could get some
balls and do something different but it
didn't it didn't work like I've been a
[ __ ] it didn't work later
it often it made me feel god I'll set my
hair down and to this day I'm a loner I
don't like being around people I don't
you know I don't communicate with people
well huh
I don't know I crazy [ __ ] thoughts
and [ __ ] people up all the time you
know I just you know if I see you
boozing up losing that kid I really oh
let me change this I'm a dog lover
enough to house my [ __ ] father I'm a
tailor like I feel it
this [ __ ] we had two buildings
my grandfather gave was to build in
sheepdogs most beautiful dolls in the
world they had a litter of puppies so
yeah he was buying the food for the dogs
well just three or four days they had to
eat so I told him he can with dad we
need dog food dog he made his take the
puppies and put him in the back of the
[ __ ] pickup truck took him to unknown
neighborhood and one of that hit by a
car and he made us warm out in the
street through the poor puppies in a
minute or a god damn street in the
[ __ ] Street and the dogs and he takes
off in a truck I remember everybody was
a [ __ ] dog I really was all look look
at me my brother and I got in a pickup
truck I guess I guess the baby looked at
we looked at him because my father his
days there my son hated me ever since I
did they said a man I want man I wanted
to literally push his ass out the
[ __ ] truck and let him feel how the
[ __ ] dogs feel so one day he had just
long cahit one day he was I don't know
he was some around on the [ __ ] Street
[ __ ] around on my mother and he came
two o'clock in the morning somebody
domed him from this somebody was how do
you said he somebody clipped the way you
say it
[ __ ] from somebody from the side I said
anything Tibo me debone him and he broke
all this [ __ ] ribs and honestly he
couldn't he couldn't work for a long
time never I remember I remember
thinking that something was wrong me
because I was saying yeah you motherf I
was thinking to myself I never said
there's nobody I was thinking myself
well yeah you [ __ ] how much to
give her throw my puppies in the middle
of [ __ ] shootout in Cerritos so God
didn't wear one of them had guy head got
hit by a car broke through now you see
how that [ __ ] feels you do dirty
[ __ ] Oh
I love my dad but always I just wanted I
just wanted to sit down and talk to
atone you get you can't treat your kids
like you can't you come here your money
you got you get you [ __ ] me up do you
[ __ ] in in a long-term I'm gonna end
up somewhere duh
like here yeah and I can kind of see it
and this [ __ ] but for some eat
even to this day this is not even to
this day if somebody tells me something
compliments me about something I've done
all I can hear is my father tell me you
ain't [ __ ] you ain't never gonna be [ __ ]
I remember we're in a that that voice
that voice that voice is always there
telling me that I'm not gonna be nothing
into this day I think that I'm not gonna
be an even if I when I feel like I'm I'm
something that Boise is always sends a
strong just wrong oh it's a stronghold
in my mind it tells me you know you
can't even when I die I had a set of
drums I was a drummer and remember I
couldn't I couldn't keep the rhythm
because I couldn't keep I couldn't get
the constant I couldn't concentrate
because the voices in the back of my
mind telling me oh why are you doing
this you can't do this you you're sorry
you're dumb you're stupid remember we
want to keep one well we went to the
woods of the barbershop and I remember
with we scores barbershop in the in a
real ghetto part of town and some of
these guys are come on Saturday and you
know he's got all white back me and
coming in and talking [ __ ] about
what the line but what they bought and
what the kid on him just one guy looks
at me now my dad is sitting here this
[ __ ] sitting here I'm his son
and the son of the [ __ ] tells me guy
Lily if you was my son I'd kick your ass
every [ __ ] day they made me finish
let me for no stop I mean I'm red on a
roll this [ __ ] tells me this is
my I'm tell me if I was your father I'd
kick your [ __ ] ass every
[ __ ] day now what [ __ ]
you sent over to them glasses I know you
were [ __ ] you a punk you scared to
fight now my father's [ __ ] sick if I
would say if that mother [ __ ] told my
son some [ __ ] like our final blooping is
there one for Justin
I'll keep telling me sorry this is what
this [ __ ] is saying yeah I'm
feeling it now this [ __ ]
he's agreeing with this [ __ ] so
one day one day I don't know why I
couldn't get in the house
so I'm poking out to get in the house
and he said you know I like that guy
said I'm gonna start kicking your
[ __ ] ass I'm just supposed to you
just need your ass kicked
let me tell how that made me feel that
hurt me such a bad guy
well hey why I'm not I'm trying to do my
BAM I said I'm just just existing and
just bogus cuz the way I'm looking I'm
just a bad guy i I never I remember I
never thought I never thought I was
smart I was I was a dumb you because I
was told I was old I remember I had just
ballet class in high school and I
remember this big buff guy like one of
my sisters in the heat and engine and
she said if if if you do bad on this
test i'ma tell you now if anybody my
father heard her I got a feeling on a
test he would he would he would be my
eyes so [ __ ] bad I was afraid of him
so we had it we had a test on on a
microscope we had a name everything on
the microscope night failed everything
and when he said that they were gonna
tell on me I took that micro and for the
first time in my life I studied I got
everything right on their microphone I
remember when when she asked me cookie
ask mr. purchase what what it done he's
gone okay
he said I was I always thought something
was wrong with his with the doctor the
teacher said I always thought something
was wrong too because it's my last name
he sits in the front of the class and he
never anyways his hand he never says he
he just stood there looking at her and
everybody face he may know something and
I'm still I'm doing what the guys did
you know borrow something woman add say
anything like I said why is there at
something I mother you know I'm thinking
this this big guys big bump I look like
he doesn't I am and you sitting there
[ __ ] sitting here making faces
this is what I look like
it's telling this is why but he got an A
in the class so I said well god damn I
can't I guess I can't do it you know I'm
gonna go back my father
big-big times in for this [ __ ]
he [ __ ] my life up I took her
afro-american class and I gotta pee but
a first time my life cuz it's it is to
be iron [ __ ] history but history
didn't mean [ __ ] to me because if she
did Jimmy they have devil to do with me
as far as me and my heritage I don't
wanna I wanted always one of my daddy of
just how I told my father to be properly
if you have me make do something to make
him proud of me I said dad I gotta be
just you know what this [ __ ]
here I for making history that's a
[ __ ] Claire that that that guys even
do the paper huh little paper in the
track so I feel like I wanted to say me
you finally did some good you find you
something right then [ __ ] steel
steel has had that negative [ __ ] to say
about me and I just think I just I don't
know why he hated me I don't know why I
don't know why you hate him matter why
he I don't know why he warned me I don't
know I just don't why you hating me
someone but until this day that [ __ ]
haunts me and cuts me and all and it
just it really just [ __ ] me up but the
last time he really authorized me when
he told me about my car my kids don was
playing daddy
even as I'll talk about that she made me
want to cry because I'm 19 what can what
can I do to please you [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] if anything in the world I can
do to PU so this [ __ ] gets a new
wife and yours new kids these kids are
all successful these kids go to college
now and I remember being on his house I
remember it seen who held diesel
[ __ ] to have he's hugging his
mother for nothing well he never hooked
me here of mother my little brother all
you did was talk [ __ ] to her do this do
that he never you never told us he never
played football there mother [ __ ]
everyone to the football game he never
[ __ ] when I played the drum he never
came to the goddamn game
my brother's complaining as he grabs
from school and the mother [ __ ] I
didn't he said I'm gonna cry school he
said only eating keep paying no
attention I mean I didn't know what do I
have never been Mira I can't I can't
kind of [ __ ] like I can't come into a
woman
I gave me because I cut up cuz i think i
think that i think i think it I'm not
good enough work I don't know how to I
don't I don't fight it now not another I
can't shakes no more I don't I don't
know I've never been financially I don't
know how to I don't know I mean he my
dad was so good at paying bills he was
real smart he was good at paying bills
and being organized you never showed me
that he just said go to school you need
to go to school when I like even tell me
go to school in his team when I was too
too stupid go to school well what the
[ __ ] do I do
do I have to do who do I go to I didn't
trust nobody
just nobody so I never learned how to
pay bills and keep and budget and not
everything I ever had a job I get my
whole [ __ ] checking just [ __ ] spin
it no other you know I don't know so
much of what girls I've had they've
always been intubated I dunno how to do
with a pudding pop that's all I had to
do I can't do that [ __ ] now for the last
five years like they do in the journal
war
I just can't do it no more so here I am
and I know I know it's even even to this
day I'm I told my therapist and I'm
seeing me I'm seeing me I can see all of
me that I don't I don't let people dick
try nothing that people dictate my life
today
I am so grateful I think God sent you to
have me to have you to have you to
having it's so much more I think I said
just just to have you as at this camera
here in front me as an outlet to how my
life was really [ __ ] up and in it I
could I could I could I could go on and
see which way to wine
but it's because my dad was all I had of
the men doing you know he tells me
[ __ ] kicked me in that beet mash told
me I wouldn't [ __ ] yes and that that
that was a scar on me but that's that I
don't think I was funny mr. dad doesn't
call me that I just I just it just it
just is hard to talk about it
but for some reason is like nobody in
the room but it's like it's like I'm
glad I can see her talk about this [ __ ]
you know I mean I've never I never I've
never really told him I didn't want how
cuz I always thought that the guys are
supposed to be tough for me I've always
played that way but I'll deep down
inside of me I was always afraid and
scared you know and always thought I was
lasting and now you know I didn't never
kid never fight I just I just never had
no self-esteem but nothing I'm seeing
alright [ __ ] now I want I'm in my own
place
I mean I just I just and I laid in on
YTV I just I don't want to go nowhere I
don't want to you know I just I just I
still think that I'm a nobody
so when I pick up that bottom alright
nobody [ __ ] goes away but do you want to
when I come down I'm right back there
again you know and on I don't take care
of my my kid today because they took my
kid for me
when he took my gear for me
are you said my kid that joke there's
some [ __ ] and I couldn't have her 18
years ago I have not lived so that day
I have not lived I have a AG for myself
because I feel like one more time I
failed and it goes through my mind
almost all day every day I find what
kind of man didn't get sober long enough
or his kid wouldn't come on like that
and I kicked myself in the ass every
[ __ ] day and I don't care what nobody
says you gotta forgive this song I
cannot find it nowhere in me to forgive
myself for [ __ ] it get over what I
did I saw that kid shake like a crack
maybe one day 18 years ago I can't sleep
at night because I see that baby shake
Oh
i'm just-just my family just I'm just no
they don't want to do it not just the
worse it's worse than them I'm really
nothing I'm I'm really nothing out to
them I'm really nothing out so in spite
all that I'm nothing to me either
so mama my whole life is really [ __ ]
I'll walk around here smiling this [ __ ]
like everything is go Kay because that's
what you tell me to do
hey everybody know if everything is not
okay cuz I feel really really [ __ ] up
any shitty inside and sometimes I just
want to go fuss I don't know I just
wanna do some time I just sometimes I
just want to crazy [ __ ] you know just to
get to get off the you know yeah because
I think you've wonder how cops pick up
our primary one just took a gun and went
out there's you start murdering people I
think all the party wouldn't bought a
gun and start shooting mother mother
because cuz that's that that's that's
hot that's dusty the anger and
frustration and I build inside of me
behind all the [ __ ] you hold on my
life him when they took my [ __ ] kid
change my kid's name to another name and
told my kids that I'm not her father I'm
uncle I change your name now if that
ain't enough to make a [ __ ] one
alone take a shotgun just gonna blow it
by see why do people go postal because
I've I thought my name was matter of
fact when they said that when they when
they told me that my kid wasn't coming
home I walked in the liquor store
and I took the bottle off the rack I
said I'm taking this [ __ ] and you ain't
gonna do a [ __ ] thing about it and I
walked out and didn't nobody come out I
came out for me I said I'm taking this
[ __ ] and you ain't doing [ __ ]
about it they just I'm crying they just
took my [ __ ] baby and I need
something to drink and I ain't got no
money dude I said no disrespect but I'm
taking this [ __ ] and he didn't
come get me I never forget that day
that's when I read that that's when I
really knew I had that the out the
problem of the alcohol is sitting
because I really I stood there and I
average person when you tell somebody a
kid kids not coming home because it's
drugs and alcohol average person
wouldn't quit first thing I did was wind
Goblin I realized that day uh-oh there's
a problem
something's going on there's a problem
here so that was all for that and uh
I can't exhaust from everything I said
if I cannot stop here my good now he
will keep going alright you want you are
given a break and do another one later
yeah yeah okay okay okay okay come on I
didn't see the whole life stuff I never
talk I think we'll be doing any of these
I never told nobody that you but you
know what you said well can I think it
still but but even but even I feel even
though that this I feel better because
because I got all public you know what
I'm saying I admire therapies as all
they told me I won't tell her this [ __ ]
well some of it but not too deep did you
know I got some more deeper [ __ ] you
taught me more than your Joanie a
therapist oh hell yes because you cuz I
owe ya come on CQ you know for each pin
your handi not valued you have in your
hand and you know and she looks you mean
I don't know I get a lot of [ __ ] from my
comment from my viewers saying then they
comment saying I don't pay attention and
and you see how many people are outside
I'm supposed to pay attention to every
single story all day long is yeah these
people are like yeah but down texting me
and everything else which you you this
is but I think you this this is more
they called better no conscience can't
you learn a lot about just bought people
in jail because even human there you
being here because because I'm learning
I went through I went through an alcohol
rehab but I never there with there was
two therapist and I remember they said
it 98.9% of families in America just
functional well that blew my mind
because I thought ours was the only one
it was this poison because I saw the
nice car in the driveway and if you went
in the house they had the pole he's
coming over there people getting thrown
on the windows and dollars you know our
cars being my brother got my brother cuz
my dad I was gonna fight him over the
Exodus I mean it was it was I got hold
on okay sure think should think sure
thing excellent mmm all right man thank
you so much for coming see you next time
no problem no problem
thank you
you